Over the years, Batman has more than earned
his place in pop culture legend — and for
more reasons than one.
He boasts a remarkable rogues' gallery, he's
a key player in super-teams like the Justice
League, and he's a merchandising juggernaut
to boot.
And of course, you can't ignore arguably the
most important aspects of Batman's iconic
appeal: the Batsuit.
As long as there's been a Batman, there's
been a Batsuit in some form or fashion.
Some are cloth, and some are rubber.
Some are armored, and some are lightweight.
They come in a range of color schemes, ear
and cape lengths, and utility belt sizes.
Regardless of the specifics, though, Batman
rarely leaves the Batcave without one.
His suits go a long way in keeping him safe,
and they help strike fear into the hearts
of Gotham City's criminals.
"What gives you the right?
What's the difference between you and me?"
"I'm not wearing hockey pads."
Still, as badass as many of Batman's costumes
may be, the truth is they're far from perfect
— and if you place them into a real-world
context, some serious issues begin to present
themselves.
Arguably one of the most glaring problems
has even been examined by physicists, who
explained why a Batsuit wouldn't work in real
life as it does in the comics, cartoons, or
movies.
Any Batman fan will tell you that most Batsuits
are incomplete without a cape.
After all, they don't call him the "Caped
Crusader" for nothing.
On the surface, the cape seems like little
more than an aesthetic choice, but in truth,
many Batman incarnations have used it for
much more than looking good.
Aside from using it as a means of intimidation
against Gotham criminals, it has often been
used as a method of gliding across large distances.
And while this may look cool on the silver
screen or in the pages of a comic book, the
truth is that this function isn't nearly as
plausible in reality.
Back in 2012, physicists at the University
of Leicester published a study in the Journal
of Special Physics Topics.
It read:
"Clearly gliding using a Batcape is not a
safe way to travel, unless a method to rapidly
slow down is used, such as a parachute."
They noted that, after leaping from a 150-meter-high
Gotham City skyscraper, Batman could realistically
glide for approximately 350 meters on a 4.7-meter
wingspan before the velocity levels off at
110 kilometers per hour.
At that point, an 80 kilometer per hour descent
would begin — causing the DC Comics mainstay
to plummet to his death, unless he found something
to break his fall.
Still, there's nothing wrong with pretending
that Batman can use his cape to glide from
building to building.
It's a fun mechanic to use in the Batman:
Arkham video games, for example, and it sets
up some neat visuals on the big screen.
But there's one other aspect of the Batsuit
that’s even less practical than the cape:
the cowl.
Specifically, those worn by the likes of Michael
Keaton and his successors for their live-action
movie appearances.
Seeing as these specific cowls consisted of
one solid piece from the shoulders up, it
would be incredibly difficult for Batman to
turn his head.
In fact, this has even caused problems during
filming on Batman movies in the past.
At a 2014 press event, Michael Keaton discussed
his struggles with the headpiece while filming
1989's Batman, revealing that moving his head
at the neck was next to impossible.
As a result, he had no choice but to move
his entire upper body for moments in which
Batman had to turn and look in a different
direction.
That's obviously inconvenient for an actor,
let alone someone trying to fight off two
or three bad guys at once.
From cape to cowl, the Batsuit is something
of a mess by real-world standards, yet it's
typically presented as the ultimate suit of
armor at the cinema, on TV, and in the pages
of DC Comics.
At the end of the day, though, suspension
of disbelief is the name of the game with
stuff like this.
As long as it looks cool, that's all that
really matters.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.